accordin Pakistan has sentenced a
university lecturer to death for
blasphemy
Junaid Hafiz was arrested in 2013
accused of insulting the Prophet
Mohammed on Facebook he spent nearly six
years in solitary confinement waiting
for his trial on Pakistan's
controversial blasphemy law carries an
automatic death penalty it's yet to be
actually be carried out but the law has
drawn widespread condemnation from
rights groups as , Haider explains from
Islamabad Junaid Hafiz came to Pakistan
from the US and was hired as an English
literature professor he's a Fulbright
Scholar and of course has also earned
praise for his academic work however a
group of students then objected to his
Facebook page accused him of blasphemy
in 2013 he was arrested and charged with
blasphemy under Pakistan's law 295 C of
the Penal Code that is the Pakistan
Penal Code anyone who defies the name of
the Prophet as it provides for a
sentence of death in this particular
case Hafeez had been in jail since 2013
it's been six long years a number of the
judges have already been changed and
today the verdict was read out on the
maximum security inside the prison
because back in 2014 his lawyer was
gunned down and so he of course
according to reports was kept in
solitary confinement because of fear for
his life but that particular judgment
coming out inside the jail in Multan